the strands in your eyes they color them  one I've been looking forward to this  moment ever since baby Tommy was cut out  of my abdomen cheers  [Music]  it's time now  there are pirates and they took  everybody a message where is the pattern  of the pride  Robert Robert calling you thanks a lot  Carol  here's the plan we're gonna head to the  next Island for help oh my God  this weekend hasn't exactly got a plan I  reached chasing he wasn't on your vision  board you're the only thing on my  mission is that blood  [Music]  go see  just you know I looked over there and I  saw the blood and you know I think I saw  some brain was that brain stuff well you  know what maybe we should let's just  step away  [Music]